benvenuti
probabilmente almeno una volta vi sarà
capitato di fermarvi a ricordare il
passato e osservando il presente
chiedervi se foste appagati per voi
stessi per la vostra vita o per il
vostro lavoro
io ad esempio
me lo domando di continuo e per quanto
mi sforzi di poter rispondere con
sicurezza questa domanda
la verità è che non mi sento quasi mai
soddisfatto
anzi spesso capita che le persone più
grandi ma anche quelle della mia stessa
età
mi dicano ma si tanto sei giovane
hai tutta la vita davanti
devi saperti accontentare di quello che
arriva
e lo sono sentito dire veramente un
sacco di volte
e probabilmente
ve lo sarete sentito dire spesso anche
voi
vi faccio una domanda
alzi la mano
chi ritiene di sapersi accontentare
una mano alzata
ottimo è una cosa positiva
adesso però mi faccio un'altra domanda a
cui dovete rispondere con piena
sincerità
alzi la mano chi si sente appagato e
ritiene di aver raggiunto il proprio
obiettivo massimo nella vita che sia
questo lavorativo o di qualsiasi altro
tipo
come immaginavo le mani alzate non sono
state poi così tante
raggiungere un obiettivo importante
d'altronde richiede tempo
a volte anche degli anni
ma raggiungerlo con successo necessita
uno sforzo ulteriore
non è così scontato poter dire di
sentirsi appagati soddisfatti e io ho me
lo domando di continuo e quotidianamente
mi chiedo quando raggiungerò il mio
obiettivo massimo
ma soprattutto se arriverò mai a
raggiungerlo davvero
comunque per chi di voi non mi
conoscesse già mi presento di nuovo
brevemente io sono lorenzo ferrari e mi
definisco un curioso e instancabile
appassionato di marketing e pubblicità
da ormai due anni infatti trasforma
questa mia passione in contenuti
originali informativi destinati ad
appassionati e professionisti
ma oltre a questo sono anche consulente
di personal branding e il fondatore di
klever a divi e smart oulx due progetti
che ho avviato nel 2020
sapete
spesso le persone mi chiedono cosa mi
abbia spinto a intraprendere questa
avventura
portandomi dall'essere uno studente
universitario che passava le sue
giornate sui libri a studiare lamentarsi
di esame impossibile
a salire sul palco di un telex per
raccontare la propria esperienza
me lo sono chiesto tante volte anch'io
e a distanza di tempo mi rendo conto che
non è facile per me in primis trovare
una risposta a questa domanda
quando iniziato l'università ci andavo
per costruirmi un futuro e studiavo per
passare gli esami fine queste erano le
mie principali attività come studente
universitario
nel poco tempo libero che mi rimaneva
invece mi dedicavo al dolce far niente
io lo chiamavo relax ma la verità è che
spesso mi annoiava morte e di rilassante
c'era ben poco
la mia vita ad ogni modo era solamente
studio studio ancora studio mi sembrava
quasi che non ci fosse spazio per altro
ora io sono sempre stata una persona
fortemente creativa e curiosa
quindi immaginatevi uno studente
universitario come me pieno di voglia di
fare di realizzarsi di concretizzare
quello che stava studiando a cui mancava
però un solo fondamentale elemento il
tempo per farlo
era veramente frustrante
mi guardavo attorno e mi sentivo quello
indietro quando invece era lo stesso
punto di tutti gli altri
ma forse è stato proprio questo che ha
fatto scattare in me una scintilla
ricordo allora che in un giorno di fine
estate ho scoperto linkedin è un social
network che fino a quel momento non
avevo mai utilizzato ma che avevo
sentito nominare spesso
un po per noia un po per curiosità ho
quindi iniziato a scrivere contenuti su
alcuni argomenti che stavano simili di
studio
principalmente di marketing
sarebbe bello dirvi che ho avuto subito
successo
ma la verità è che
per i primi tempi non ho proprio
ottenuto alcun risultato
zero interazioni a proprio zero cioè non
mi calcolava nessuno
nonostante ciò ho deciso comunque di
continuare e ogni giorno
scrivevo il mio post
aicon ogni giorno intendo proprio ogni
giorno 7 giorni su 7 365 giorni l'anno
festività incluse
ecco a distanza di due anni continuo a
farlo anche se con un seguito ben
maggiore rispetto a quando ha iniziato
a volte mi fermo a pensarci e mi chiedo
che cosa mi abbia spinto a insistere
così tanto
d'altronde anche andare in palestra fare
pesi sembra essere più piacevole e
proficuo di svegliarsi ogni mattina
pubblicare un post
eppure per me due anni fa non era per
niente una cosa scontata
anzi la prendevo con molta serietà quasi
come se fosse un lavoro stipendiato
il motivo per cui lo facevo all'inizio
era una forte voglia di mettermi in
gioco di emergere rispetto agli altri
lo considerava una sorta di investimento
per il futuro in quanto stavo
letteralmente investendo del tempo per
cercare di premi una strada verso il
mondo del lavoro
ea me bastava quello per uno studente
universitario che nel mondo del lavoro
non c'era ancora entrato era sufficiente
cercare di aprirsi una strada
quando poi però mi sono reso conto che
il mio seguito stava crescendo dopo mesi
di costante attività
sono subentrate altre dinamiche come la
volontà di trasformare la mia immagine
personale in un vero e proprio brand e
quindi fare personal branding
o la necessità di arrivare non più alle
persone e farmi notare direttamente
dalle aziende così da incrementare le
mie possibilità lavorative
alla base di tutte queste motivazioni
comunque c'è ancora oggi una forte
passione
una passione che ho condiviso secondo il
mio punto di vista dando voce alla mia
creatività e alla mia voglia di
differenziarmi
sapete
a questo punto le persone solitamente mi
chiedono
cosa mi abbia spinto a continuare
e perché continua a fare tutto ciò
beh la risposta che mi sono dato negli
ultimi tempi a che non sono mai
veramente soddisfatto
negli ultimi tempi non ho fatto altro
che inseguire degli obiettivi
che non ho mai veramente raggiunto
anzi a dir la verità ogni volta che mi
sembrava di essere salito sull'ultimo
scalino davanti a me ne comparivano
altri 100
è come essere in una lunga galleria
in fondo vedi la luce pensi che
finalmente ci sia riuscita
poi però la luce rimane lì e l'uscita
non si avvicina
ho passato mesi a cercare di migliorarmi
a fare di più
eppure ancora mi sembra di essere fermo
allo stesso punto delle volte
penso che possiate capire la sensazione
di stress e frustrazione che si prova in
questi casi
sarà certamente capitato anche voi
almeno una volta nel lavoro nella vita
personale
quando poi nel 2020 ho creato clever a
divi e smart all xvi il primo con lo
scopo di raccontare il mondo
pubblicitario è secondo con l'idea di
divulgare il marketing in modo più
semplice accessibile
la mia vita è cambiata notevolmente
e se da un lato ci sono stati tanti
cambiamenti positivi
dall'altro questa ricerca del
miglioramento continuo e portato passare
dallo stress al burnout
all'ansia
pensavo che la cima della scalinata
avrai raggiunta dando alla luce ciò cui
stavo lavorando
ma non è stato così
anzi aver creato qualcosa di concreto
mi ha letteralmente prosciugato
togliendo del tempo a me stesso
allo studio alle amicizie alla famiglia
ea tante altre cose
tutto questo per raggiungere un
equilibrio quello che di cui vi ho
parlato fino ad ora che però in realtà
non ho ancora veramente raggiunta
ma allora come fa raggiungere i propri
obiettivi senza rischiare di andare a
schiantarsi contro un muro
la risposta che mi sono dato è trovando
un equilibrio
a tal proposito mi piace molto una
citazione di sua miss acida nanda che
per chi non lo conoscesse era un famoso
muro di yoga indiano
lui diceva non cercare la soluzione
trova l'equilibrio
esso porterà la soluzione
vedete per me è proprio questa la chiave
per raggiungere l'upgrade con successo e
sentirsi realmente appagati
nella mia breve esperienza ho passato
tre quarti del tempo correre a cercare
di inseguire gli obiettivi
cercando la soluzione per arrivarci nel
minor tempo possibile e spesso
rischiando di danneggiare me stesso e il
mio stesso percorso
ma ricordate quando vi ho detto che ogni
volta che mi sembrava di aver raggiunto
la cima della scalinata davanti a me
apparivano altri 100 scalini da salire
ecco col senno di poi forse se avessi
rallentato un po e mi fossi concentrato
sui singoli step del mio percorso
oggi potrei dirvi di essere più vicino
al traguardo
c'è però una cosa che non vi ho detto
fino ad ora abbiamo parlato del grade
come appunto un obiettivo una meta da
raggiungere
beh almeno per me
l'upgrade è invece un percorso
se ci pensate la vita stessa è un
continuo grade e sta ciascuno di noi
sentirci appagati e soddisfatti
abbastanza e decidere quando per potersi
fermare dire ok sono arrivato e mettere
un punto
vi faccio un esempio banale si può
scegliere di smettere di studiare a 22
anni perché ci si sente pronti ad
affrontare il mondo del lavoro
così come ci si può lavorare a 90
insomma se c'è qualcosa che ho imparato
è che per arrivare in cima alla
scalinata e raggiungere l'upgrade
bisogna fare molta attenzione a dove si
mettono i piedi
perché a volte basta perdere
l'equilibrio un attimo per rotolare giù
vuoi tornare da dove si è partiti
finendo per perdere anche tutti i
progressi fatti
vedete
io
me lo domando sempre
è una domanda veramente costante quando
raggiungerò questo upgrade come lo
raggiungerò
la verità è che
ho scelto di seguire
quella citazione che vi ho fatto prima
di swami perché ho trovato veramente
illuminante
e ho capito che
per raggiungere questo traguardo
bisogna semplicemente fare attenzione al
percorso che si compia
perché solamente così
che si potrà scegliere quello migliore
grazie
[Applauso]